which meant that
so so you've become a millionaire
through this process
yeah yeah
boom shagger
what a great thing to be able to say
you've gone red-faced just thinking
about it
yeah i'm thinking about
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i want to introduce you to a guy who
just made 850
000 pounds profit on
one deal that is absolutely ridiculous
he's a successful scottish entrepreneur
his name is cameron he's one of my
students he's part of our academy and
you're going to hear exactly how he did
it in this video but please first smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
for more videos just like this but right
now cameron welcome to winners on a
wednesday thank you samuel thank you for
having me so you are literally that is
probably gotta win the trophy on on the
best deal of the year so far yeah i've
been very lucky it's been a fantastic
deal
um in doncaster
um
how it kind of started out was um i was
at the crash course in september 19 yeah
and
i was on the stage got the highest roi
went up and i just loved it it was
amazing great atmosphere really positive
and i thought i need to take some action
i thought what should i do and i thought
okay i'm in my comfort zone being in
glasgow doing the things that i do
um i have to try something in england
completely different set up from glasgow
regulations were different article four
so i thought do some due diligence in
the area that i learned from the crash
course just
simple things and i thought i wanted to
take some action straight away let's get
get a deal find something and decided to
go
to doncaster of all places because
there was a property on hmo available i
think it was a four bedroom it was going
to be converted into an eight bed with
planning permission
but unfortunately it just wasn't as was
described in the description went there
and it was a complete botch and it just
wasn't going to be viable
um as far as the figures and the amount
of money i'd have to spend
so the the agent that was showing the
property said we've got another property
if you're interested and i thought okay
and it's an ex-council building would
you be interested and i says well we can
you know i says yeah sure we can have a
look it's not that far from here it's in
the city center it was excellent um and
he goes i'll give the vendor a call
vendor came out to see me and um looked
at this building i thought this is huge
yeah you know this is something i've not
done before and interestingly that you
didn't go to view that property it just
goes because i remember at the crash
course saying the person who's used the
most properties wins
don't see it as a property viewing see
it as an appointment with an estate
agent yeah because you know i came all
the way from glasgow to see this hmo
yeah and i thought you know i've got
this other opportunity
went to see the building the vendor came
out to see me lovely guy got on really
well
and
um and i said well i think this might be
too much for me you know it's huge you
know the purchase price was you know i
was looking for the region of about 360k
and i thought how am i going to raise
that one yeah i don't have it and then
obviously there's refurb cost the
conversion
you know um i was a wee bit out of my
comfort zone
but then
i was like this is what i should be
doing yeah so it says listen
you know i'll get back to you right in
that time i was you know pondering over
the fact you know what should i do how
can i
raise money um to do this project and i
thought okay
from the crash course i learned well
i've got these properties
that i could refinance yeah so i thought
this makes sense and you had a nice
little portfolio in glasgow and you
would they were just basically buy to
let's yeah and i just didn't um i was
old school you know i didn't have
you know the reason why i came to the
crash because i wanted to learn how can
i maximize what i have yeah you know
you know and i thought okay um
refinance because most people
their mindset is pay off the mortgages
as quickly as possible that's what it
was work hard pay off pay off i know i'm
saying no
pull out more equity get more loans
against the properties that's it and and
you know it was like interest only and i
thought okay let's so i thought got some
advice off
people that i thought knew a bit about
property in glasgow they advised me to
go to like um somebody that would
arrange finance and i thought fair
enough
so um they wanted a percentage say i
think it was two and a half percent yeah
and it was coming to about approximately
about twelve and a half thousand pounds
i thought that's a lot of money fair
enough got to do this and move forward
um got the ball rolling but i was really
favored up to do the launch pad because
at the crash course i joined the academy
and i thought pay the whole lot i'm
going to do this i'm going to spend some
money on myself yeah for a change
educating myself about something i'm
passionate about
that i've been told that i'm good at but
i've done on a part-time basis yeah and
i really want to scale up and learn how
it's done because there's people with
such less experience than myself
that are smashing it and i thought you
know if i get this education favored up
for the launch pad it was november and i
thought it's november's 80's away like
i'm really so desperate to start
um okay so november came launchpad came
loved the environment um there's some
great people i met obviously yourself
and alistair and anthony and started
talking to everyone and just loved being
around really positive people
that were into what they were doing they
were in part of the training they paid
for the training so there was no messing
about these guys were focused yeah and
it's great to be in that environment
interest as well though because you
cameron obviously were already a
reasonably successful property investor
you had five properties you had
experience in the in the industry in the
construction industry you trained as
like a plumber and you'd worked on
victoria a lot of victorian houses
working in retail you've got a shop yes
i've got a shop what tell me a little
bit about the shop yeah shop is like get
up at um five o'clock in the morning
open up um as you know shops are hard
work yeah anybody that's in retail
traditional grocery shop in inner city
scheme which is fantastic place to do
business again um it's hard work and i
wanted to you know property was always a
part-time thing because shops retail
businesses take a lot of your time yeah
they're very focused around the owner of
the person that's you know me um so
and i was thinking you know
the money that i make from there i can
put into property and expand my
portfolio um that was the idea but i
never really had the time
yeah you know because shops do tie you
down right so you're kind of making
money with your with your shop where
what are you selling is it like an
off-license i think it's just a a daily
and a growth source okay yeah just yeah
you've got a shop you're making money
off of that you're working really hard
saving your money then you're dumping it
into property which is quite an
old-school
way to become wealthy of course it is
and you know it was always the thing
that you know you worked hard and you
know if you buy a property that you want
to pay off as quick as possible yeah you
know that that was this general scenario
you know that you were brought up with
yeah and but i had to have you know move
forward and kind of modernize my way of
thinking yeah and my approach towards
property because you know i think um i i
was told i was very good at what i'd
done that i should be doing it full time
you know the the shop you know okay is
the shop but there's so much more you
can do yeah so with the five properties
and they're in a nice part of glasgow as
well where about salt lake they're in
the west end of the west end of glasgow
okay like the golden circle yes
basically very close to the city centre
10 minutes walking distance 10 minutes
from glasgow university so these five
properties that you've got the first
thing we said when you join the academy
is you you're thinking how can i
restructure this how can i reshuffle
this around so so what did you do with
those properties what happened so
what i did with them um one of them
that's slightly outside and it's like
more a suburb of the west end so it's
maybe
the other the other four are like
walking distances city centre and i
thought okay
what i realized was that you know maybe
i think i did the right to rent we
learned about service accommodation so
it says
let's try it out on this one property um
it was a single let
1100 pounds per calendar month great
occupancy done well yeah and the thing
was the tenants had been in there for
quite a while i thought this is my
opportunity they're leaving
did a full reform and just upgraded it
with some you know kind of nicer
furniture and stuff because i wanted to
do
achieve that luxury kind of yeah you
know hotel look yeah and that i was
taught through the academy this is what
you can achieve if you you know you
furnish it well and you know you go for
that high-end look which i did and you
know i was pleasantly surprised
and
i thought well how am i going to manage
it because we're taught how to manage
our service accommodation but i just
didn't have the time so i thought i'll
get competent company so i use the
company pass the keys which are
brilliant
um and now it's generating an average of
3 300 per calendar a month incredible so
you've trip you tripled the
the the rent basically i would never
have been able to do that without the
training and learning yeah you know the
potential in that because it just didn't
happen i mean even just that deal alone
even after you take up all the costs of
the of the management and and whatnot um
the extra profit if you spread that out
over a year that's paid for the academy
yeah well definitely and the best part
of i forgot to say um about my academy i
think i paid 12 000 pounds yeah
at the time says that's a lot of money
so i'm going to make sure now this is
money i've spent myself so i really need
to get something out of it so when i had
was refinancing my portfolio wanting to
have a pot that i could buy property
with and especially in england that i
was looking um i obviously started that
process and it was declined
and i was like you're having a laugh you
know and in that time i had obviously
looked at a development that had been
offered in doncaster
and i was like gosh what am i going to
do now you know i've spoken to this
gentleman
and i've gave him my word um um so i
thought
i was at the academy event
and i thought
i was i think it was a sofia from penny
house deal finding extravaganza i never
used your own money again yes yes that's
what it was and i was just listening to
you know that
she does refinancing and stuff and then
one of um the other academy members
raised she said to me listen i've used
sophia she's great why don't you speak
to her because i was in a crisis i was
like what am i going to do i've just
gave this gentleman my word that i can
give him a quick sale that can purchase
this building that i'm so out of my
comfort zone
and
because i've joined the academy now i've
got that confidence and i've got people
around about me that will support me and
can answer questions and help me um so
arrange a phone call with sofia and she
says okay
i want to refinance these properties
it's been declined but it wasn't
declined because of anything to do with
me personally
my credit history everything was top
notch you know there wasn't an issue it
was just that a mistake that the person
that was refinancing had made okay so
and she says okay send all the stuff
over sent it over and she done it for
like 1500 pounds and she pulled out all
the money needed yeah excellent and i
thought well there you go the you know
what i've paid to join the academy has
paid for itself from one contact yeah
because now you've refinanced so you've
managed to pull out did you buy the
doncaster property in cash yes from the
very finances
so this little portfolio that you have
then that you're renting out was making
a little bit of money but suddenly
you've
turned one of them into a service
accommodation which has tripled the
amount of uh uh rent that you're getting
next you've refinanced that little
portfolio which has set you up to buy
this property in doncaster which you
bought for 300 and 320 000 including
fees right and that was now about 18
months ago yes and it has kind of run
over because you know with i did kind of
buy it when the middle of covid yeah i
think i got the keys on april but we
didn't start work till june right
because i wasn't happy with the outline
plans i looked at them and i thought i
think i can improve these yeah and also
i was looking at the development
thinking
i'd love to build on top of this
and do something i wanted to add even
more value in houses yes okay so let's
have a quick rundown what happened and
then we can go into a bit of detail
about some of the lessons so you bought
it for 3 30. 320 320 sorry
how much because i know the refurb now
you still want to do you want to add a
bit more work onto it and do penthouse
but the the main work of the uh
of the properties is now pretty much
complete you've also had a parminder
who's giving you a conservative
revalue on the property so you bought it
for 320 how much did the refurb come in
at in total to convert it and what did
you convert it to sure okay i converted
the it was uh next council building um
and it was within the cartilage of a
listed building so it was a wee bit
complicated
um
i converted it into a 3000 foot
retail unit um and on the other side
it's a five bed with all ensuites hmo
and then on the first floor is a 10 bed
with all ensuites hmo and i've just been
granted permission in the last few
months for penthouse apartments
not so this is a mega building and with
a wrap around roof terrace and they've
got a small car park as well
right so um yeah i'm really excited
about doing the penthouse apartments i'm
very proud to check manage that myself
yeah and do all of that um
yeah so it's been
amazing wow i bet the lessons have been
crazy you know it's like
if you can imagine doing
one deal but learning about planning
permissions about
dealing in with conservation officers
yeah with local councils and being
technically in a different country
because i'm from scotland yeah rules are
completely different of course you know
even you know the tenancy agreements
users are still using short assured
tenancy agreements we don't
in scotland they've got their own
the scottish government
so
it was in one development i've done
commercial
that i've got a tenant for the
commercial unit now and i've obviously
doing a new build as well because i'm
building the penthouse apartments yeah
on an existing building the hmos um
so it's been a mix of everything in one
year and also you've done it alongside
the academy which is perfect because
you've had the you've had all the
training and education but you've been
doing it alongside and learning on the
job i've had some great support from you
know
like to yourself alistair anthony and if
i had you know
everything just ran along with the
academy events and if i had any
questions
everybody was there for us you know to
support us it's got other academy
members as well you know dave taylor was
a great help remember chattington we
started our journey about the same time
yeah because you you joined the academy
with dave yeah
and and you know i remember taking him
out when i got the keys yeah getting his
advice was great yeah you know and
met ray through the academy you know um
there's some fantastic people that have
helped me and she's done fantastic as
well yeah she's she's doing great and
you know the amount of support i got
from her her experience and knowledge of
basically you know how to do things in
england how to deal with the council
it's been and she says the same about
you though and that's the thing with the
academy you've got the mentors but then
you've also got success buddies people
helping each other along the way
so all in what's the cost of the
purchase price of the site and the
entire development cost refurb what does
it all come in that it's coming in at
6.50 650 including purchase price all
the renovations and completing the whole
project so 650 including stamp duty all
the build cost professional fees and the
purchase price i buy it for 320. okay
and you've just had paul minda give you
a conservative very conservative
valuation and what is that coming at 1.5
million oh my goodness which is amazing
how did you feel when that came in
uh unbelievable
i just couldn't believe it i remember
actually asking anthony how do you work
out like an end value yeah you know uh
on and he was says well
give me an idea of what kind of rentals
you're expecting this was yeah early on
and
i
told them the figures i'd done the
figures i got them to check them
and i was like that are you sure
he goes yeah believe me this is you
because though it can't be yeah this is
it you know so when you were working out
what the invader was going to be were
you thinking this can't be right if i'm
buying it for 320 and i'm spending
another 3 30 and based on the rental
income because obviously you know the
commercial unit the you know they take
into consideration what the rental is
yeah you know to give us an end value
and then the hmos you know and i was
explained how it worked and i i just
couldn't get my head around it yeah so
that's a clean profit of
000 pounds on one deal and a rental
income of eleven and a half thousand per
calendar a month per month eleven and a
half grand gross obviously so once
you're refinanced do you know what kind
of cash flow profit you're going to be
left with a month yeah i i think you
know
conservatively about five to five and a
half thousand okay so you've got about
eleven and a half grand rent you have to
pay the mortgage once you've refinanced
bills different bits and bobs um but
still that's that's not only is that 850
grand in equity that's also financial
freedom yes and you know i remember
doing the buy refurbished free finance
yeah and this is the perfect buy refund
oh yeah
oh it is
you know basically it's paying i'm
getting a free property and i'm getting
money back yeah oh
you know the whole theory what we're
taught i think um yeah
well if you wanted to you could probably
if you yeah i'm not saying you should do
this but you could sell the entire site
and then probably if you you shouldn't
do this but pay off the mortgages on
your um yeah
i mean the world's your oyster but i
wouldn't i would imagine to continue
growing growing growing i would be
keeping this pot for the next um
development um the thing is you know
having that
cash flow to look at another project and
other things and
you know i'm really excited now um
being back amongst
everyone you know with
with yourself
like alive
well we were training together yesterday
yeah and it was great it's been a while
you know
and i haven't even finished the academy
i've still got a couple of things to do
yeah and you know i've still to learn
about deal sourcing
and you know the one-to-one mentoring so
i'm really looking forward what i said
to you as well as i said the amount of
opportunities that you come across that
you're like i'm too busy on this this
and this you should be packaging and
selling those deals and you're like i'll
get to the deal selling masterclass soon
yeah um which is which is incredible
also you had um i know you just came
down from glasgow yesterday to do some
development training yes which which is
awesome which is actually outside of the
academy and that's a whole whole new um
venture and what happened in the build
up to the development training that you
did with myself
and i think i was in newcastle and i
thought i want to go to a live event
because you know it's been so long and
just to get around you know seeing
yourself and around like-minded people
so i went to the event in newcastle and
you know obviously you were speaking
about you know the development side of
things new courses running yeah and i
thought well you know this sounds
amazing
um so what did i do
i decided to take some action after i
came back from newcastle and this was
last week yeah last week roughly yeah um
i looked at some land and put on offer
and thought i want to do this now
um i just was desperate to take some
action and this is a bit of land that
had um it had 16 it was an apart
basically a tournament block with a pub
that goes right round and it was it went
on fire
um i'm not going to say much more about
it and it's basically to reinstate it
again
um so i'm really looking forward to
doing that and i've putting an offer
through the solicitor and it's located
it's a clean offer um which the clients
are looking for i know we spoke about
that and i was like have you got
planning permission and and we were
chatting through and you said that
you've spoken to the yes planning i've
had a chat with the conservation officer
and the planning officer um this is
something i learned previously
you know working in doncaster um you
know i'm a people's person yeah like to
meet people face to face and talk to
them and you know put across what i'm
hoping to achieve and get their support
and again i approach the council looking
for their support
and their advice on
what i want to achieve yeah and it was
very positive and they said they'll work
with you and get the planning
so the um the land what was the offer
accepted to buy the land for and the
offer for the land is 30
37
786 pounds why so specific
uh i don't know it's just that i like to
i know people say why do you i've always
purchased things with you know the odd
numbers and 786 this is a luck thing as
well okay all right good so there's
still 37 000 submits for a piece of land
that's very cheap yes but we're probably
in six 12 months time we'll have another
story of how you made it a million
pounds on one deal because you've got a
lot to build on that potentially a lot
of houses and stuff yeah so um again
it's
having the conversations and yeah
if it's just picking up the phone
you know and the this land that there
was offers in before
and it was um subject to planning yeah
and you know
the vendor's not really looking for that
they just want to quit their cash
but then the thing is you know how to
speak to the planning department and the
council and they'll say we know the site
here's what we think you can get the
feeler of course you know there's no
harm in that and also if it goes all
wrong it's only 37 grand
it's worth a point stick it back in an
auction and set it for 25. yeah that's
it you know at the end of the day it's
um
you don't have to take some kind of
risk you know
property development
isn't easy by any chance even refurbs
the thing i was doing in doncaster
believe me i had so many
so many problems you come across but
it's finding solutions for those
products correct and having
a network of support and people around
you that you can
seek advice from yeah and
i find that that is really important you
can't pull off a big deal like that
without any sweat no no no it's not it's
not easy you know there's you know
there's especially when you're dealing
with properties in conservation areas
and there's listed buildings there's a
lot of
there's a lot of things that you have to
learn about you need the training i mean
it's just it's like if you want to be a
doctor you go to law school if you want
to be an electrician you go to college
if you want to be a property investor or
developer you've got to get the training
and
the this the training with yourselves
you know
you know beginning when i started the
training people said oh you're doing
this training you're doing that i was
yeah i'm doing it and you know people
are quick to pass judgment yeah but you
know come along and see what happens at
these training events
you know you know i'm very experienced
and
learning about different things and i
think the training is fantastic yeah the
people that you'll meet um you know
thank you samuel
you're welcome thanks for coming i know
it's great to have that opportunity and
being introduced to all the different
people through yourself you know and i
think what you're doing is fantastic
and um
yeah i appreciate that yeah it's amazing
what is your strongest reason for doing
this
my strongest reason for doing property
or
um
for making all this money you know
there's got to be a reason for making
all the time
the
firstly it'd be nice to be able to be
you know
not have be able to get up whenever you
want in the morning yeah do the early
mornings because you're still doing
retail right now i'm still up at four in
the morning when are you gonna quit
doing that well once um i'm in a
position where you know doncaster once
the rent comes in that's another thing
as well about property development and
that's why on the academy we teach rent
to rent and deal sourcing because
property development is really slow like
yeah you've just made 850 000 pounds
equity on this on this uh on this pro on
this property but until you actually
get all the tenants in and
you don't see the money no that's it
you know you do have to my advice would
be telling you that you know
you have to keep paying your bills you
need exactly i need money coming in cash
flow is the lifeblood of any business
and the thing is
in property your money can be tied up
for a period of time yeah so
um for me you know i can't afford to not
be working yeah but you've got your
retail business which is giving you your
cash flow at the moment and then you've
got property which is you're working
part-time on your fortune and full-time
on your
on your job
but i think for some people they haven't
got that retail business they haven't
got the cash flow which is why we teach
rent to rent deal sourcing and lease
option agreements these strategies we
can get some quick cash flow coming in
this is a great thing about the academy
there's something
that suits everyone yeah that if you
want to get into property
you know i was speaking to a few people
yesterday and you know their everyday
situation's different correct you know
some people you know have money to
invest some people don't but there's so
many creative strategies like right to
rent yeah you know event to service
accommodation you know
you know there's lease options
you know these things are all taught
yeah
and also if you
some people might watch this thinking oh
it's all right for cameron because he
had his five houses with his equity but
the thing is if someone didn't have the
five houses with the equity but they'd
have found that doncaster deal they'd
have very easily been able to find a
joint venture partner on the academy and
gone in 5050s without a doubt i remember
discussing doncaster
and obviously the the process of the
purchase and everything that was going
on is i was at academy events at the
time so i was having to leave the room
and speak to solicitors and you know
negotiate things and you know i didn't
have a shortage of people wanting to
joint venture right because obviously
some people are aware that my refinance
had been declined oh right so that i was
in a panic i was like because i've given
somebody my words you know yeah and
there's going to be a delay i bet a lot
of people wish that they hadn't been
able to join venture because putting in
a few hundred grand and then getting
that kind of an uplift it's incredible
did you use bridging finance for the
actual development no what did you use
your refinance money refinance money all
of your finance money and in a way it's
been a blessing in disguise because um
i looked into bridging and whatever i've
learned through the academy but the
project is overrun no fault of my own um
it's just because of covid people you
know the company i'm using their staff
being in furlough yeah you know just
generally issues
that builders are having just now yeah
and materials and stuff um just you know
that's just the situation yeah um so and
i was thinking if i'd had bridge in
finance
and the project has run over right you
know i suppose in a way you know it's
been okay i'm i'm funding it myself
if it had gone wrong
let's say i know this is impossible
because you're doing your due diligence
and you're on the academy yes but if
that if if you do all the money you put
into that deal if it had all gone down
the drone
would you what did you put every penny
you had into that deal or did you still
have lot money and different things
elsewhere how did you put everything in
i've
basically
refinanced my whole portfolio everything
you put everything into this deal
everything which is 650 grand yes which
meant that
so so you've become a millionaire
through this process
yeah yeah suppose yeah
boom shaka
what a great thing to be able to say
you've gone red faced just thinking
about it
yeah well i'm thinking about it no yeah
but you are now you're a millionaire
yeah because you're if you add up all
what you've got now and you take away
all the debts you left you over a
million pounds oh yeah easily but you
weren't a year ago no so you're a
millionaire yeah that feels that's a
good feeling
i know you're one of the reasons you're
doing this is to be able to get out of
retail yes also your daughter yeah
amelia yeah amelia's um my daughter
she's just taught five and emily is a
child with ds which is down syndrome and
um
i just want to do more yeah to help her
and you know it'd be great to have the
extra money to do things
and be able to you know there's there is
support out there but you know there's
stuff you can do privately to help her
basically you know reach our milestones
quicker and also you know i'm very
passionate about
um certain charities that i've been
involved in over the years but it'd be
great to have that actual
financial freedom and time
to be able to go personally and do the
projects instead of just raising money
and contributing money towards these
things yeah
and yeah it's not it's not all about the
money for me yeah i really want to make
you know
a change
to people's lives and the difference
yeah
yeah
you're and you're a great guy i know
your dad as well who uh who's passed now
but he set up schools in pakistan yeah
which is still which is still running
running to this day yeah for children
that can get an education they can even
stay there yeah you know like a bit like
a boarding school and stuff yeah
and you know it's something
that you know inspired me to think that
i'd love to be able to do that myself
continue that work and physically be
able to travel and do these things yeah
you know
and i think
i get a real good
you know feeling from helping people
that's awesome well you know what i
couldn't i couldn't be more happy for
you
and you know you're a stand-up guy man
of your word you've got great energy
every time you come to the events you've
always got fantastic energy and um i'm
just so so happy and i'm really glad to
be part part of your journey and i'm
really grateful that you've come all the
way from glasgow to share the story on
windows wednesday likewise i just like
to say a big thank you to all the team
yourself samuel and anthony allister um
ricky you know these guys have really
changed my life awesome bro thank you so
much well done
guys if you're not inspired i don't know
what to say cameron what a great guy
what a great story if you want us to
come to the property investors crash
course like cameron did and experience
the training that we've been talking
about then guess what it is on the house
okay free ticket on the house i'll leave
a link in the description so you'll be
able to check the next date up and
coming and get down whether you're from
glasgow whether you're from ireland
people come from all over the world to
these training programs because they
genuinely will change your financial
life forever if you implement and put
the work in
i've been doing interviews like this
every single week for years now every
week another success student coming on
the channel every single week on winners
on a wednesday you can check out the
entire playlist up here but of course
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
so you can see more future videos book
on to the next property investors crash
course god bless peace out see you next
time
[Music]